on va retrouver tout de suite notre
envoyé spécial à kiev clovis casali
bonjour clovis que peut-on attendre de
ces pourparlers à la frontière entre la
biélorussie et l'ukraine
alors l'ukraine a accepté par de
participer à ces pourparlers de paix
mais sans trop y croire c'est ce qu'a
déclaré le président à hélène ski mais
il faut donner une chance à la paix bien
sûr un moscou dit vouloir un accord un
mais les ukrainiens ne veulent tout
d'abord un cessez le feu immédiat mais
aussi le retrait total des troupes
russes qui ont envahi le sort ukraine le
sol ukrainien donc il y aura forcément
la question aussi des territoires à
l'est notamment de donetsk et de
louhansk que faire dans ces zones là
parlons un petit peu des délégations qui
seront présentes à ces pourparlers de
paix côté russe il y à un conseiller du
creux du kremlin medinski ancien
ministre de la culture qui est aussi un
ultranationaliste qui a toujours oeuvré
parlé du besoin d'avoir cette grande
russie est chère à vladimir poutine et
côté ukrainien eh bien il n'y aura pas
le président bien évidemment mais y aura
le ministre de la défense et le vice
ministre des affaires
étrangères à présent pour parler à paix
pour essayer d'obtenir ce cessez-le feu
dont les ukrainiens ont tant besoin
dernière information les russes disent
que tous les civils peuvent partir de
kiev et que ce sont les ukrainiens qui
sont en train de se servir des civils
comme boucliers humains là je peux vous
dire qu'ici la situation est très
compliquée pour ceux qui aimeraient a
quitté kiev il ya encore des sirènes qui
retentissent constamment très
régulièrement il y en avait une il ya à
peu près une heure invitant tous les
habitants à se rendre au refuge et bien
sûr il ya des combats toujours pas dans
le centre ville de kiev mais autour et
de nombreuses routes sont endommagées
donc compliquée pour les civils de fuir
la capitale malgré les affirmations de
moscou alors justement clovis à vous
trouver à kiev le couvre-feu a été levé
pour la journée les ukrainiens peuvent
donc de nouveau sortir dans la rue
lorsque les sirènes ne retentisse pas on
l'a bien compris que vous dites s'il ces
cesu ukrainien
eh bien regardez il y à des ukrainiens
dans la rue mais pas autant que
d'habitude bien évidemment alors alors
même que nous sommes dont le
centre-ville avec un mes collègues
abdallah malka oui et rob parsons nous
sommes rendu tout à l'heure dans un
petit supermarché pas très loin d'où
nous restons en ce moment à l'hôtel et
bien je peux vous dire que l'ambiance
était particulièrement tendue certains
clients clients parler un tout petit peu
trop fort et la propriétaire du
supermarché leur a demandé de se taire
ou de partir les gens sont à cran bien
évidemment avec ses jours de
bombardements de raids aériens de moscou
des raids aériens russes qui ont visé
des immeubles parfois résidentiel avec
des civils dans la capitale kiev quand
on parle aux ukrainiens ici des
pourparlers de paix ils nous disent
qu'ils ont très peu de chances d'aboutir
qu'ils sont méfiants qu'il ne croit pas
aux paroles de vladimir poutine ils
disent aussi qu'ils ne sont pas qu'il ne
déteste pas à les russes qu'ils ont même
des membres de leur famille parfois en
russie mais qu'ils n'ont pas confiance
en vol a dit mir poutine il parle d'un
ennemi cruel qui souhaitent détruire
l'ukraine les ukrainiens ici son antre
scepticisme méfiance mais aussi
abnégation et combativité c'est pour ça
que vous avez tant d'ukrainiens qui ont
pris les armes ou qui préparent des
cocktails molotov et qui sont prêts à
s'interposer pour empêcher les chars
russes de passer aux alentours de kiev
clovis des explosions ont encore retenti
ce matin à kiev ces temps où se trouvent
les forces russes autour de la capitale
ukrainienne
oui la nuit a été agitée avec plusieurs
sirènes qui ont retenti
on sait qu'il ya eu des raids aériens et
aussi à des missiles russes tiré à kiev
et autour et dans d'autres villes bien
sûr de l'ukraine alors où sont placés
les charrues c'est bien ils n'ont pas
encerclé
kiev a priori les ukrainiens disent que
c'est une fake news que les russes
disent qu'ils ont encerclé qu'ils aiment
mais que ce n'est pas le cas et que kiev
est bien aux mains des ukrainiens qu'ils
tiennent bon et qu'il contrôle à la
ville en tout cas les russes a priori
non pas encerclé la capitale mais sont
disposés sur certaines sur certains
points stratégiques autour de la
capitale mais il y aurait encore des
routes pour sortir donc les russes ne
contrôle pas encore la capitale et
les ukrainiens disent que de toute façon
ils tiennent bon et que les russes ne
contrôle pas les r non plus alors que ce
sont les affirmations côté russe
dernières informations les ukrainiens
viennent d'annoncer un bilan des
opérations selon les selon les
ukrainiens toujours il faut prendre les
chiffres avec des précautions 5000 trop
russes ont été tués près de 200 chars
russes 191 pour être précis des dizaines
d'avions aussi donc pour l'instant les
ukrainiens se félicitent de leur
opération pour repousser l'envahisseur
russe mais bien sûr les ukrainiens
veulent qu'une chose c'est la paix le
cessez-le-feu et l'arrêt de l'invasion
russe merci beaucoup clovis casali en
direct de kiev